now trying to pressure the media into
giving him better coverage the white
house is not happy with how the press
has been talking about inflation and the
supply crisis so a group of senior
officials are reportedly holding secret
meetings with major outlets and are
trying to convince them into more coerce
them i should say into more positive
coverage and it looks like the view got
the message loud and clear
the question is why don't people want to
hear the good news for a change
you know
is that what we need to to hear when
something good is happening here you
said you know that people are not
picking up on the good stuff i believe
that that's because the media is not
portraying him as a winner they are
minimizing what he is doing when the
chips are down americans are going to
understand that if republicans take
control of this country again we are
done as a country we are done
now believe it and they actually applaud
what do you say jesse that's an
enlightened crowd
you might want to go on there i know
yeah for the next book yeah we might
have to do the view um do you realize
how bad things must be for a democrat
president to be begging democrats in the
media for a better spin haven't they
done enough judge i mean they spiked the
laptop they ignore the border they
cheerlead all of his mandates and they
write stories like why inflation is
actually a good thing yeah i mean like
what else could they do it's like me
telling johnny like johnny you have to
do more you're really not doing enough
like what else could johnny do
breastfeed jesse jr honestly i mean if
he could i'd ask for it but the thing
that's going on here is this
biden has some nerve to ask the press
he doesn't even talk to the press he
turns around like he's deaf every time
he stares talking he's done two sit-down
interviews since may last time i checked
it's december what does he do he clowns
around at a town hall with lemon or
cooper the whole time he hasn't even sat
down with the ap reuters washington post
new york times wall street journal and
then he complains about bad coverage
he's not selling his agenda because he's
a poor communicator and so his team is
going to all the journalists and saying
can you be a little bit more like jen
saki try to be a little bit more like
jen and if he had good results those
results would sell themselves if he was
reducing crime inflation illegal
immigration but that
cases
they're saying he's not communicating
properly is he not communicating
properly or is jesse right that he has
limited the number of interviews and is
continuing his campaign bunker strategy
i have to imagine that if i were those
report those newsrooms that got one of
these visits i would say excuse me
because we haven't heard from him we
haven't even talked to him like we can
ask jen saki questions she's the press
secretary she's very available and she
answers all the questions might not like
the answers but that's what they are he
doesn't do he's not selling it and they
i i read these headlines um biden's
communicators are to blame no they're
not
and also they miss opportunities all the
time but it comes from the top for
example the other day they could have
had a great press conference and said
well guess what omicron not as not as
lethal as we thought yeah so this is
great news and in fact guess what you're
not gonna have to wear a mask on a plane
something like that like they could make
decisions based on science actually that
would that would help them but this is
the same white house that demanded
better coverage for the amazing airlift
they did out of afghanistan it was like
people were falling off of planes this
is the white house that said that
republicans were the ones that wanted to
defund the police they had to backtrack
on that they said that inflation wasn't
happening then they said well it's just
transitory when people are basically
seeing that
in the in their own lives but also in
the statistics that come out so i i i
got to hand it to them like to go in
like they know that they have a problem
so that they're going to go in i don't
think that it's going to change though
the view saying we should all be happy
and celebrate the wins it's not going to
change the fact that when you're at the
grocery store and you see somebody in
front of you that basically is like
counting up the
items and having to put away the rice
krispies treat ingredients
and i heard this from a democrat on the
against the grain podcast
that stuff's real it is real but but
greg what about the allegation that the
press is underselling the good news what
is the good news
it's hilarious i mean here's it this
reminds me of a guy going to another guy
and pleading with him to talk him up in
front of a girl he likes right
yeah exactly i do that you know when i
talk to the ceo at fox about jessie
jesse's really coming along but it's
i mean think about it when the view
becomes your public relations arm yeah i
mean i guess i guess the cast from teen
mom was busy because i mean this is i
mean it's amazing how almost like
robotic that was but i love also how
this is posed as a secret meeting behind
the scenes is it right we it
acknowledges the fact that the biden
white house is indeed a facade like a
storefront from an episode of gunsmoke
and you just right behind that's just
fake it's all this other stuff going on
they don't know what the hell is going
on i just long for the good old days
when trump would just trump didn't do
trump would talk to anybody and
everybody he knew exactly what he was
thinking and he of course he did call he
the only people he called in the news
were commentariats right he never like
went to the heart they didn't call up
anybody didn't call it bret bear i don't
know you'd be surprised
he called everybody everyone
maggie but everything he said on the
phone he would say on tv
joe doesn't talk to anybody except for
himself when he's muttering in the yard
yeah all right jessica now think about
it the white house has three other
senior officials trying to talk to the
press and the one that i thought was
most interesting to persuade the press
to give them better coverage was the
ports envoy yeah i guess he's going to
tell him the supply chain problem is
isn't as bad as we think it is well
ports are top of mind for people yeah
because so what's the good news well the
good news actually i thought this was
interesting today joe manchin put out
this he carries around a card
of the administration's accomplishments
joe manchin who i find to be
relentlessly negative actually in terms
of democratic causes actually walks
around with this and talks about the
coveted relief act talks of the
bipartisan infrastructure act money
people need money and they like money
and republicans love money more than
democrats do so that should be a good
thing oh this money is going well go
ahead
they clearly know there's a problem and
there were two things today that struck
my interest on this front one that joe
manchin carries around this card and two
the monmouth poll that showed that
inflation and kitchen table issues are
top of mind for basically every voter no
matter your partisan affiliation and
that's what they're having to run
against and having a ports envoy have
this conversation or people who aren't
joe biden who i think does actually
pretty well in these interviews is not
going to hack it for the american public
and so that needs to switch around
before the midterms come around and
people want to see their president hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else